[Music]
welcome to Hannity live on this busy
news breaking Friday 10:00 tonight so
much to cover including yeah
forgetful Joe's shifting recollection on
civil rights issues also we will bring
you a Hannity history lesson on the real
Democratic Party and their disgusting
hypocrisy on the issue of race in
America will challenge the media mob to
ask real questions of real hypocrisy of
their friends at the Democratic Party
plus we have shocking new footage
violence against police chaos continues
in all big cities across America first
we turn to breaking news out of Seattle
tonight where anarchy now reigned
supreme
roadblocks checkpoints border walls
armed Vinci vigilantes vandalism
extortion this isn't some failed third
world country it is a scene from
Seattle's prominent Capitol Hill
neighborhood just a short distance from
the iconic Space Needle now the six
block area in the middle of the city has
now been blocked off by a group of well
socialist revolutionary wannabes and
they're calling their little socialist
utopia quote the capitol hill autonomous
zone or chas for short now in this
little slice of Socialist heaven all
police have been kicked out in fact the
local police precinct was totally
abandoned by city officials subsequently
taken over by the so-called peaceful
demonstrators which is putting everyone
inside the autonomous zone or autonomous
zone at risk take a look how calls for
service have more than tripled these are
these responses to emergency calls rapes
robberies
all sorts of violent accident have been
occurring in the area they were not able
to get to anyone with a functioning
brain you have to know this is
unacceptable but well the mayor of
Seattle Jenny Durkin is her name is
either too stupid or too incompetent to
care she's actually letting the
anarchists take over control and even
destroy her city in fact she's calling
this autonomous zone patriotic last
night on fake news CNN she predicted
that it would lead to a summer of love
Wow take a look how long do you think
Seattle and those few blocks looks like
this I don't know we could have the
Summer of Love well tell the heads of
the police who was supposed to be in
that precinct though but I understand
your sentiment mayor we don't have to
sacrifice public safety for First
Amendment rights both can exist and
we'll make sure that both exist in
Seattle they took over parts of the city
they took over police precinct summer of
love armed vigilantes checkpoints
vandalism of course a community garden
and the police they're not invited
there's what do you call that I thought
that was discrimination they even built
a border wall tough on immigration
policies hmm sounds like discrimination
against law enforcement to me and I
thought liberals were against these
things and believed in inclusiveness and
diversity and open borders not here
president Trump now vowing to restore
order but the mayor in this particular
case is calling any federal intervention
unconstitutional and illegal she doesn't
know anything about the law either now
I'll say this my unsolicited humble
advice is this if she doesn't want help
and by the way that's fine and her
fellow Democratic governor the ever
incompetent Inslee both of that will be
fully responsible for the demise of this
city and this state the president has
now been offering once again to help
help help would you like us to help we
can help you restore order they choose
they decline the president's offer my
attitude at this point is okay if that's
how you want to run your city in your
state and you want the anarchists to
take over okay you deal with that
problem on your own now I hope and pray
become that bad because then the
president will have to get involved
otherwise I'd say your city your state
have fun but get this as late as
Wednesday governor jay Inslee had no
idea that these autonomous zone was even
existence in existence wasn't even
happening no idea whatsoever so I don't
know what's worse him not knowing or him
really knowing and afraid to say he
knows and that would mean to have to do
his job and meanwhile one Seattle City
Council member is now pretending that
the zone is quote a street fair with
political discussions in a drum circle
and the mob and the media oh they're not
doing their job if this was a
conservative group of any kind
right-wing Pablo habla they would have a
very different part of their coverage
but they're painting a rosy picture
conspiracy TV MS DNC calling it a
pedestrian street fair CBS News yes
touting the zones art displays also
known as graffiti ABC they called it a
festive zone with festive like
atmosphere imagine if this was a group
of concerned conservatives right wing
nut jobs whatever you want to call them
not really conservative but real
extremists because that's what this is
this is the far left which has now
becoming the mainstream of the
Democratic Party back to fake news CNN
they actually actually are applauding
the peaceful nature of the
demonstrations well that was until their
report in fairness to them it was just
as they said until it was totally
derailed by one of the peaceful
protesters in the summer of love take a
look despite the fact that this all
began with force this what you're seeing
in front of me is a peaceful situation
in fact it sort of looks like a street
festival is this an area that has been I
mean the president makes it sound like
this is an area that has been taken over
and is being ruled by you know somebody
you know there's being ruled by by you
know by I don't know how we would
describe them
yeah well folks can certainly come and
go can't you see the festive atmosphere
don't you feel the love in the room let
you feel the Summer of Love in the
autonomous zone that the governor the
dopey mayor are letting them take over
part of their City New York toilet paper
times of course they're calling this
quote a homeland for racial justice okay
you don't own this property they just
stolen it nobody's stopping them
including the police precinct but when
two members of the african-american
council actually accused the autonomous
own demonstrators of hijacking their
message they were practically booed off
stage now for the Socialists the
anarchists inside the autonomous festive
free summer of love zone
this isn't about reforming police their
list of demands oh yeah sounds just like
the Democratic Socialist Party that the
mob and the media loves all their
socialist journeys but now in the near
term those taking up residence inside
property that's not theirs the
autonomous zone they're begging for
weapons and cigarettes and Gatorade
there you go oh also vegan meals and
according to reports these lawless
autonomous Summer of Peace zones are
filled with angry socialist vegans maybe
by the way coming to a city near you
tonight at least one governor is vowing
to maintain law and order all credit
goes out tonight the Tennessee Governor
Bill Lee he's warning these
demonstrators that autonomous zones
summer festive freedom zones they won't
exist or be tolerated in Music City USA
in the city of Nashville and this comes
as law enforcement officers around the
country well they continue to be
attacked targeted demonized in sick
disturbing ways over now eight hundred
hurt some killed the lawless liberals
continue to just double down on
lawlessness and anarchy and they
basically are allowing everyone to run
while look at the city of Minneapolis
guess what that City Council just voted
on a plan to replace the entire police
department with a new public safety
model so
who are you gonna call when there's a
serious violent crime in Minneapolis and
these lawless radical ideas
guess what come as shot a cops all
around the country are being hit with
bottles and rocks and bricks and Molotov
cocktails shot at run over doxed online
and it keeps getting worse and worse